ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
fällt meine lieben freunde und wir
dürfen gar nicht lange zeit verlieren
denn ihr seht es bereits im titel
eingeblendet wir werden heute mal wieder
in eine höhle gehen dass sie ganz
einfach daran weil in der letzten
episode durch das ganze quatsch abbauen
im netz meine diamant spitzhacke voll
kaputt gegangen ist und wir die halt mit
diamanten reparieren müssen ihr vater
jetzt wahrscheinlich etwas gesagt wir
gehen in eine höhle
warum schützt die jetzt die ganze auf
dem feld das hat auch einen grund denn
wir benötigen ebenfalls eine menge brote
unsere village auf der willicher insel
denn die sollen sich vermehren bis ich
wieder zurück bin aus der höhle in der
nächsten oder übernächsten episode ich
weiß nicht wie lange wir dort sein
werden
allerdings habe ich generell noch ein
paar andere pläne erstmal die ich machen
möchte bevor wir runter unter die erde
gehen und da würde ich euch jetzt erst
mal ganz kurz direkte time labs
einblenden
[Musik]
ich bin fertig ausgerüstet für die höhle
ihr seht schon in der linken hand habe
ich das toten der unsterblichkeit dass
wir uns in die kommentare geschrieben
dass sich das dort einfach halten muss
wenn ich sterbe und dann sollte es
funktionieren ein gott der bambus becker
ist ja ordentlich hoch gewachsen was ich
allerdings auch noch mitgenommen habe
ist ein beschädigter amboss denn dann
kann ich direkt meine glück spitzhacke
und in der höhle reparieren auch sicher
habe ich mit den eisen waren mitgenommen
und ein bisschen akazienholz bretter
essen werde ich mir gleich noch ein
bisschen mehr holen ein bisschen erde
kann nie schaden knochenmehl keine
ahnung warum ich das mit am start up ist
aber einfach so mit ins inventar
reingerutscht und zudem habe ich auch
noch eins der glas mitgenommen denn mir
wurde auch unten in die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich damit einfach lava
zu bauen soll und man dann ärzte besser
entdeckt zudem habe ich noch ein
bisschen was an meiner insel verändert
ich habe zum beispiel hier einen
eichenbaum hin gesetzte dann habe ich
hier vorne den weg ausgebessert den habe
ich nämlich in der letzten folge aus
versehen bis hierhin gesetzt dann habe
ich außerdem hier volle noch einen weg
hingesetzt der zum lagerfeuer führt so
dass wir uns hier einen witz vorlesen
lassen können
tatsächlich seien und was ich da gemacht
habe war hier den weg so ein bisschen
raus gebessert dass er hier so lange
läuft das fände ich glaube ich ein
bisschen schöner kann ich auch mal ganz
großes knochen mir nehmen damit sie sich
einen zugewachsen nach aussieht dass sie
glaube ich so auch ganz nice aus und
jetzt geht die sonne schon wieder unter
das heißt wir gehen auch mal ganz kurz
schlafen es tut mir leid dass ich immer
bevor ich dann mal wirklich zum
hauptthema des videos komme immer noch
kurz ein paar andere sachen von meiner
to-do-liste abarbeiten muss aber wir
müssen halt ein bisschen vorankommen
jedoch seht ihr schon ich habe mir ein
bild gemacht dass aktien heute habe ich
irgendwie vergessen da hinten den glock
ich wollte noch mal ganz kurz wegnehmen
und ich habe mehr 30 brote gemacht die
ich ihm jetzt hinschmeißen
ihr seht schon nehmen sie sich und was
sagt er dazu
ich stelle den jetzt einfach mal hier
vorne noch zwei betten reine vielleicht
kriegen dies er dann auf die kette
irgendwie kinder zu zeugen ich glaube
auf jeden fall an euch und wir setzen
uns jetzt mal rüber in mein brötchen der
dieser schwertner
ich bin da so rein fakten hat man
gesehen
ich bin so verknallt in mein schwert
alter dass könnt ihr euch nicht
vorstellen ihr sieht allerdings schon
dass ich nicht wieder normalem eine mine
nach unten fahren und auch nicht über
meinem ein kart strecke dort links mich
bewege um zu meiner anderen höhle zu
kommen wo wir vielleicht auch noch ein
paar unerforschte wege haben denn wir
bewegen uns dorthin zu dieser insel
ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich wenn
ihr das projekt noch nicht lang
verfolgen sollte haye luca da hast du
überhaupt schon auf dieser insel ja vor
ganz ganz langer zeit haben wir hier mal
ein paar bäume ab gefällt und da habe
ich mich noch nicht so richtig getraut
hier vorne in den höhleneingang so
richtig rein zu gehen hier gab es
nämlich so einen kleinen von daher
steige ich einfach mal aus der einzige
ort und ihr seht doch schon hier sind
doch so ein paar laubblätter also ich
war hier wirklich schon mal bevor ihr
wieder jemand mit cheating vorwirft hier
vorne war ich schon mal da sieht man
eine kleine fackel schon die ich dahin
gesetzt habe allerdings geht es hier
fordert tatsächlich rein
auch schon schön hier
wir wollen uns allerdings nicht mit
meiner welt der partie beschwert
ich bin so stolz darauf allerdings meine
lieben freunde darf ich euch recht
herzlich willkommen heißen ja heute zu
einer neuen höhen expedition mit luca
ich werde alle fackeln wieder auf die
linke seite setzte so dass ich nachher
den weg nach hause finden werde und
werde mir auch jedes erz mitnehmen denn
das bringt immer erfahrung zwei meter
drin direkt zwei zombies und jetzt geht
es hier weiter in der höhle meine lieben
freunde
ich weiß nicht wo wir lange gehen wollen
wir vorne geht es einmal runter und hier
geht es erstmal ein bisschen hoch werde
ich mich hier weiß ich ob es hier noch
bei twitter ist das kannst du doch
wirklich nicht ausdenken wie viele
creeper hier um schulen alter
was ist das denn hier schon wieder ich
hier kommen schon wächst hier das kannst
du dir wirklich nicht ausdenken
das ist doch unfassbar hätte irgend eine
höhle wo es so viele monster sind wir
vorne sind wir wieder relativ nahe und
respektiert er gibt den gleichen
bahnsteig der ganzen es ist nicht zu
fassen dann geht es weiter
[Musik]
der
hier vorne
wenn wir allerdings noch nicht das
wasser geht hier okay hier geht's auf
jeden fall weit runter ich werde ganz
kurz mal eben ausleuchten und die ärtze
mitnehmen bzw mit euch zusammen hier
noch kurz gruppen da gehe ich gleich
sein ist mir erst mal noch zu weit und
hier vorne ging auch noch einen gang
rein in der seite möchte erstmal ganz
kurz abchecken
dass von ihnen keine monster kommen
jetzt noch ganz kurz die ärzte ab wo ich
euch keine teilnetz einwände
ich glaube dass es logisch weil bevor
mir irgendwie während keating vorwirft
dass sich mit kohle und eisen kita alter
da gibt er noch die welt unter ihnen
hier vorne ist aber das heißt wir sind
auf jeden fall schon mal ein bisschen
tiefer jetzt auch die erste schlacht der
ich werde hier gleich hingehen ich werde
erst mal ganz kurz schauen wo der
wasserfall uns hin geführt hatte auf der
anderen seite ich glaube das ist eine
riesige schlucht aber das finde ich auch
eigentlich ganz geil da ist man eisen
sind verschwunden
finde ich auch eigentlich ganz geil weil
wir noch einmal eine richtig riesige
schlucht haben das ist in wien
das ist meine leute
erstens bonner ich höre auch
irgendwelche komischen geräusche direkt
schnell wieder zu bauen da waren prima
ich hab richtig schiss garde
ich höre komische geräusche und ich bin
von allen seiten angreifbar plus wir
haben hier lava und dementsprechend der
mine
ich habe hier richtig schiss gerade ich
konzentriere mich erstmal darauf hier
das reisen mitzunehmen
jetzt ist auch dunkel geworden weil ich
die lager abgebaut habe ich habe immer
so schick wie in solchen minen weil ich
mir immer denke ich hier ist auf jeden
fall eine menge redstone hier vorne
gehen wir jetzt mal als nächstes land
ich habe schon die oben schielen auf
jeden fall spinnen das sind sogar
nächste nicht diese giftspinnen das hier
ist eine ganz normale spinne glaube ich
allerdings haben wir hier vorne ja
wieder einen corner
[Musik]
wir freuen uns auf jeden fall wieder ins
bonner und vor allem auch eine menge und
seide ich werde mich in vorne auf erst
mal ganz kurz noch mal die werkbank
hinsetzen und auch mein holz nehmen und
schon mal eine truhe hier aufstellen in
die ich erst mal einigen
[Musik]
ich hasse solche minen von jeder seite
kaum gefahren kommen
das ist wie im straßenverkehr in einer
großstadt kommen dudelt sich hier nach
oben und bis direkt wieder einem neuen
höheren gang
das ist echt so verwirrend hier
naja was ich auf jeden fall machen
wollte und dafür habe ich die workbench
auch eigentlich dort gerade hingestellt
war dass ich mir kurz mal eben ein
schwert kräfte allerdings aus
bruchsteinen denn damit können wir dann
auf jeden fall diese ganzen sachen hier
abbauen wodurch wir auf jeden fall
gelang samt werden
gefordert sind auch noch weitere spinnen
die eltern dass das tückische an den
spinnen ist halt dass sie sich perfekt
durch fäden durch bewegen können also
die sind in velen genauso schnell wie
wir die nicht in velden rumlaufen
deswegen muss unsere höchste prioritäten
abbauen beziehungsweise diese
spinnennetze hier leute 2 wächst hier
[Musik]
leute die extra
es fällt dem idioten denn eigentlich
erst mal meine komplette base
kaputtzumachen alter es muss sich alles
erst mal nur ein sortieren dass knochen
wir brauchen jetzt ganz um die
angelaufen alter also ich weiß wirklich
nicht was abgeht in meiner welt und was
ich hier vielleicht da comdirect lese
ich spiele will ich mag euch allen
gleich den kopf ab bilder vielleicht
doch da kommen dann kommen jetzt
[Musik]
dankeschön
ich spiele einfach auf schwierigkeit
normal und wir haben so einen stress
immer dieser welt das ist wirklich
unfassbar so das wichtigste nämlich mit
ihr essen auf jeden fall auch noch ein
bisschen mehr und das auch und ich werde
mir auch noch ein paar mehr neue fackeln
machen denn viele sind schon wieder
verloren gegangen ich möchte jetzt mich
wirklich einmal ganz kurz darauf
konzentrieren erstmal natürlich eine
kartoffel zu essen und dann hier vorne
alles abzubauen so dass ich wenn ich
schlussendlich wirklich den spyder
dahinten erreiche und dann auch den
spanner abbauen kann denn immer wieder
diese neuen giftspinnen alter das ist
tödlich im wahrsten sinne des wortes
wechsel einfach getarnt den hat man
einfach köstlich gesehen in den letzten
[Musik]
das kannst du dir noch nicht ausdenken
von jeder seite
alter schwede ich sehe schon kommen wir
werden die ganze folge lang uns nur
dagegen schon wir zum mit jakob oder ist
doch in ordnung
express rollt kuppel die komm rein
laufen mein schwert alles wie sorge ich
werde mich jetzt erstmal ganz kurz
darauf konnten
[Musik]
der vater auch schönen guten tag der
sind sie hier schon wieder zweiter
die spiele sonic schafft übrigens meine
lieben freunde mega spannendes spiel
megacool überlegt gerade schon sollten
einfach meine luft gehen lassen
auch denke da kommt die zeit nicht so du
auch noch mal eben weg da kommt direkt
der nächste kommt tag der offenen tür
heute kommt gerne staat hier natürlich
auch noch ein williger zombie man das
macht wirklich spaß hier mit euch ich
mach uns mal ein bisschen eine größere
spiel wurde hier so dass der ändern
werden vielleicht auch noch mit rein
kommen kann den kombi aber ganz kunst
töten
[Musik]
in der men sind schon am eine andere
liga alltag
das kannst du dir wirklich nicht
ausdenken wie hart die zu besiegen sind
da gut freunde wir werden uns jetzt
endlich mal darauf konzentrieren da
hinten diesen spawn abzubauen dafür seht
ihr allerdings schon mache ich uns dass
sie erst mal ein bisschen durchsichtig
[Musik]
ich habe uns jetzt hier erstmal eine
kleine bates gemacht hier vorne unsere
sachen ich habe auch noch ein bisschen
reisen rausgenommen und hier meine kiste
ein bisschen sortiert da schwebt alles
noch in der luft weil der offenheit noch
läuft wenn ich die kiste gerade habe ich
keinen bock die jetzt abzubauen und
alles wieder neu zu sortieren
hier vorne habe ich extra treppen hin
gemacht damit nur wir hier hoch kommen
dafür muss ich das ja allerdings noch
mal ganz kurz eben abbauen und hier auf
der seite kommt auch niemand hoch zudem
habe ich uns hier türen hin gemacht dass
wir genau wissen okay hier kommt auf
jeden fall niemand rein und jetzt werden
wir auch ganz schnell mal zu dem spawn
raschen und den mal komplett abbauen
die steckt ich stecke ein scheiß auf ok
der küche auch und der zombie auf
[Musik]
alles ist ruhig in die luft wir haben
hier keinen stress mehr mit
irgendwelchen spinnen weil ich den spot
woher kommt ja
woher kommt die spinne und woher kommen
vor allem diese riesigen lauten
geräusche ich glaube wir haben da vorne
direkt noch 1 vorne
ich hasse das wenn nicht so richtig open
field hier bin und ich muss mir auch
ganz schnell mal eben noch meine neuen
freunde bei euch das mal eben kurz so
ich muss mir auf jeden fall noch neue
stein schwert machen damit ich die
anderen findet auch noch ab und kann ich
werde jetzt trotzdem erst mal ganz kurz
nach hier geben wir ein bisschen durch
waschen und gucken woran wir hier
überhaupt sind ich baue den bereich erst
mal ganz kurz zu dass von dort niemand
kommen kann und hier vorne
also dieser höhle ist komplett op
[Musik]
ja
was geht denn hier ab ich muss jetzt
raus schon wieder ich muss hier gerade
mal ein bisschen schneller durchgehend
hier unten ist lava weil ich mich mal
ganz kurz ein bisschen einerseits
orientieren muss und auf der anderen
seite auch ein bisschen ausleuchten
musst du das hier nicht noch mehr
spontan gegnern weil wir ja wirklich
schon extrem krass unter bedrängnis sind
halte was ist denn das hier für eine
höhle ich dachte die erste höhle die wir
damals da entdeckt haben wir heftig
gewesen was geht denn jetzt plötzlich
herab alter darf ich gar nicht runter
gruppen
[Musik]
ich werde mich jetzt einfach mal hier
und auf die höhe der lava bewegen weil
wir glaube ich schon ziemlich krass weit
unten sind und je weiter unten mann ist
in minecraft desto größer ist die chance
dass man diamanten findet allerdings ist
diese ganze höhle so verwinkelt ich
werde auch jetzt definitiv nicht mehr
mein base wiederfinden
obwohl ich das heutige video auch
eigentlich nicht so lange machen möchte
weil er das letzte video schon extreme
überlänge hatte das ihn einfach länger
als 30 minuten und das video davor war
er auch annährend 30 minuten
ich will diese höhle entdecken ich
möchte aber nicht sterben und ich weiß
dass ich nichts überstürzen darf hier
vorne können wir das mit der lover jetzt
mal testen da wurde nämlich gesagt luca
bei lava ist ziemlich häufig irgend
etwas krasses noch mit am start
also bleibt auf jeden fall bei der lava
und jetzt testen wir das einfach mal mit
dem glas wenn ich das hier unten drauf
bauer also es klappt auf jeden fall gut
ich kann auf jeden fall sehen was sich
unter der lava befindet allerdings
[Musik]
naja krasse ärzte sind daher leute also
ich werde nie wieder auf die leute
vertrauen die mir sagen dass sich glas
mitnehmen sollen eine höhle weil es
absolut keinen sinn ergibt hier war gar
kein einziges stück aber gar kein
einziges diamanten
da war kein einziger diamant und ich
habe ein komplettes deckglas da unten
jetzt gerade verballert bei der laga da
nehme ich mir lieber hier noch mal ganz
kurz das reisen mit
warum war es klar warum war es klar ich
gehe noch mal ganz kurz vorne eben rüber
weil hier eine spinne schild nicht dass
wir vorne noch ins bonner ist den ich
dann auch noch mal ganz kurz abbauen
kann ist allerdings gar nicht die kohle
lasse ich jetzt auch mal da denn ich
habe auch jetzt gerade wieder
zweieinhalb stacks kohle abgebaut davon
haben wir zum mittlerweile wirklich
genug die ganze erfahrung mal hin oder
her hier vorne die seite nehme ich noch
ganz kurz mit und das eisen hier vorne
auch
und dann sollten wir jetzt gleich auch
eigentlich jeden moment wieder bei
unserer base rauskommen
schau mich nochmal hier kurz eben um die
bereits die vorhin bereits gesagt alles
was wir hier ausleuchten kann und später
auf jeden fall behilflich sein und hier
werden keine neuen monster spawnen hier
vorne ich den gang neben dem finanzamt
kannst du doch nicht ausdenken in dieser
höhle wo sind wir denn jetzt hier schon
wieder
[Musik]
das war für mich der collins sind meine
pace wiederzufinden
[Musik]
ich hab so bock dass hier noch weiter zu
entdecken allerdings weiß ich dass man
dann aufhören sollte wenn es am
schönsten ist und hier vorne ist meine
face tour hinter und zu ich weiß nicht
woher die ganzen geräusche herkommen ich
kann allerdings direkt mal eben das
nächste eisen hier reinpacken und ihr
seht schon was wir allein schon alles
bekommen haben allein wenn ihr euch mal
anguckt schon wieder anderthalb stacks
redstone ein feedback golderz 46 kohle
und hier schon 1236 eisen
ich werde meinen amboss jetzt auch
einfach mal direkt hier drunter setzen
hier nämlich hin
da können wir dann in der nächsten folge
wenn wir hoffentlich diamanten finden
werden ich muss auch die kiste auf jeden
fall erstmal ein bisschen erweitern
dann können wir hier auf jeden fall in
der nächsten episode uns eventuell schon
darum kümmern dass wir meine diamant
spitzhacke ein bisschen schöner machen
bzw nicht schöner machen sondern das
überhaupt erst mal wieder funktioniert
hier die ist ja fast völlig am arsch die
werde ich dennoch im inventar behalten
das denn wie diamanten finden eventuell
noch ein bisschen was abbauen können
hier den bruchstellen behalte ich auch
lapislazuli pack ich rein
ich habe mir noch eine zweite werkbank
gemacht als ihr unterwegs war weil ich
einen wassereimer mir machen wollte für
die lava falls sich rein fallen sollte
habe ich allerdings nicht gebraucht ich
werde mir auf jeden fall jetzt bevor es
in der nächsten folge vergesse noch mal
kurz eben ein paar neue fackeln machen
denn das ist auf jeden fall extrem
wichtig so dass dort keine neuen monster
spawnen zack und zack und an der stelle
meine lieben freunde würde ich die
heutige episode minecraft mit luca jetzt
auch beenden wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann lass gern einen daumen hoch unter
dem video abonniert main kanal und
klickt auf die glocke damit ihr eine
benachrichtigung bekommen sobald
übermorgen das neue video online ist
teil zwei unserer größte großen höhlen
expedition hier
ich bin richtig müde jetzt schlafen und
wir sehen uns dann wieder chelsea
[Musik]